[Music]
you're beautiful I love you seer I love
you Tommy I gotta get into Riverdale
because you know the fans are wanting to
know is mama McCoy gonna stay in marital
bliss can you even do that in the town
of Riverdale can't you do it well let me
tell you I think if anybody has any
couple has a chance they have a chance
she and Tom right so but you never know
right you never know so those are the
moments were count on but a wedding was
nice my wedding was nice something
something uplifting on the show those
happy moments how do you think mama
McCoy is going to respond to Josie and
you know the kiss can you believe it
what she enjoys but I wasn't surprised
you know well you know I'm mama McCoy
but then I'm also a fan so I was like
yes you know yeah yeah not surprised at
all wonderful yeah and then I know we're
having the spin-off with Josie are you
gonna be a part of that anyway do think
so
I do think so that was nice to hear when
I got a little email from the executive
producer I was like yes yeah so it's
nice I'm really I'm really happy for
Ashley she's a wonderful actor and Josie
I mean I grew up watching Josie and the
Pussycats so you know so playing Josie's
mom is just it was a real fit so
thrilled for them
[Music]